las calles de este pana que tienen las
cicatrices del bombardeo de la mañana en
la capital de la república
autoproclamada de nagorno karabaj varios
civiles habrían sido heridos el
territorio ubicado entre armenia y
azerbaiyán es un enclave de mayoría
étnica armenia en el territorio de
azerbaiyán en este conflicto latente la
violencia estalla regularmente pero es
la primera vez desde la guerra de los
años 90 en la que murieron 30.000
personas que la situación está tan tensa
ante la intensificación de los combates
armenia dice estar dispuesta a buscar
una solución diplomática aunque
seguiremos respondiendo de manera
enérgica y decidida a esta agresión
contra nagorno karabaj estamos
dispuestos a colaborar con los países
que copresiden el grupo de minsk de la
osce para restablecer un alto el fuego
basado en los acuerdos de 1994 en 1995
pero en el sexto día de combates un alto
el fuego parece poco probable el
ministerio de defensa armenio publicó
este vídeo en el que se ve a un
helicóptero azerbayano derribado sobre
nagorno karabaj en la capital de
azerbaiján bajo toque de queda las
autoridades siguen exigiendo la retirada
de las tropas armenias de la región
arminio construido armenia quería ver el
fin de esta escalada armenia debe poner
fin a la ocupación basta esparta
para echar más leña al fuego ambos
países acusan al otro de utilizar
mercenarios extranjeros de hecho francia
acusó a turquía de haber enviado
combatientes sirios